es el día internacional de los pueblos
indígenas una celebración que se ha
visto ensombrecida por las condiciones
en las que estas comunidades viven entre
el olvido estatal y la violencia
desatada principalmente por los grupos
armados el narcotráfico y las
actividades de las industrias
extractivas
los indígenas también se enfrentan a las
políticas de desplazamientos
obligatorios por el acaparamiento de sus
tierras a la destrucción de su cultura a
la discriminación ya la pobreza
problemas que limitan su acceso a
servicios básicos a quien no conocemos
lo que es el servicio público aquí no
hay electricidad no hay agua
[Música]
y no hay nada mini en las carreteras
están asfaltadas según la onu el 47% de
todas las personas indígenas que
trabajan no tienen educación frente al
17% de quienes no pertenecen a pueblos
originarios mientras que más del 86% de
las personas indígenas de todo el mundo
trabajan en la economía informal y en el
caso de las mujeres la brecha es aún
mayor en efecto los indígenas siguen
exigiendo que los gobiernos respeten sus
derechos en primer lugar todos los
pueblos están exigiendo reclamando el
reconocimiento de su propia existencia
en el reconocimiento de sus derechos
territoriales
el reconocimiento de sus saberes y
formas de aprovechamiento de estos
recursos
a día de hoy hay indígenas en más de 70
naciones y en todas las zonas climáticas
constituyen un 6 por ciento de la
población mundial que a su vez se divide
en casi 5000 grupos étnicos darles el
respeto y los derechos que se merecen es
uno de los mayores desafíos sociales de
américa latina'